mm go read minds parapa today we're
playing pom gets my fight it's a game
about love friendship and dogs what the
[ __ ] am I playing I was gonna do happy
wheels today but I didn't have enough
time so I panicked okay I panicked and
this is what we're doing today okay it's
coming I know I read comments I know you
bros okay so this is pom I can move nice
best gameplay ever all right what
happened pong the sun is shining [ __ ]
god the birds are singing it looks like
the perfect day to spend on the Internet
that's me every single day okay now what
should I check first firstworldproblems
Facebook reading detail tom tumblr
tumblr the comfort
Wow this fan art is amazed good bless
this is dry but the artist is 14 why
this so talent this is impossible leaves
into active volcano okay well next up
phase wolf god stop posting pictures of
[ __ ] food I'm showing off how much
fun you're having without me no one
wants to see your Populi duck face
either get it public are you seriously
telling me I'm the only legit pom-pom
doggy on this website forget this I
don't want to live on this planet
anymore flies into the Sun another day
I'll internet well spent probably cos
you've got oh oh yeah
fire fire oh say master wake up you have
to get out of here come on this way [ __ ]
that [ __ ] Shiba Inu is so noisy
however the ceilings here looks like
it's about to collapse I what hello she
just keeps browsing Internet
fine finally that dumb sheep Hashanah if
it just me or is it hella hot in here I
only should turn up the air-conditioning
hey all that air-conditioning
yep it coughing wheezing oh we died and
went to doggy heaven huh it's much
better I can finally finish my daily
rounds I'm shaking be ready ah God ah
there's no there's no Wi-Fi in heaven oh
[ __ ] die I didn't never know doggies how
to have it just kill me now what did I
ever do to deserve this
I'm crying now it's not the time to be
salad while living in self-pity I gotta
get up and do something about this yeah
inspire oh that walk in animation that's
legit oh is that the who are you Oh
pom poopy head I'm glad you didn't get
hurt in there fire do you know where we
are
I was waiting outside your Owen
you excuse our I am huh in the corrupt
ocurro
Oh now help me look for Wi-Fi what but
isn't it more important that we figure
out to get home fast we can worry about
to Wi-Fi later
what the [ __ ] did you just [ __ ] say
to me you little [ __ ]
you [ __ ] dead kid oh oh is it bad oh
what what the palm you're kind of
scaring me what are we gonna do [ __ ]
well I can only attack tell her your
mama joke your mama's so fat even Dora I
couldn't hear hatching me
i taunt you so ugly that Hello Kitty
said your body oh no it's a super
effective all right what else have you
got oh okay okay she man from now on
you're my manservant also change your
name to the massing by the hell I
Sebastian
okay Shiba join our party nice nice
alright and somebody has to talk about
why do you have to yeah why do you have
the laptop with you anyways I'm a lapdog
after I'm pretty sure that's why am I
playing this uh well so better than call
of duty alright let's go with a rainbow
Oh like there's a [ __ ] dog let's talk
to him hi hi hi welcome to doggy heaven
thanks wait watch did you did y'all get
heaven then that means yo you got it
you gave ah if this is heaven then where
the Wi-Fi in heaven should there be
ultra high-speed Wi-Fi everywhere my
fine what oh my [ __ ]
is that a new technology I'd be not here
davon for a while
so if that's a cave than I wouldn't know
anything about it
sorry you better be sorry don't feel too
bad
it's not exactly common knowledge for a
dog to have there's no Wi-Fi and dog in
heaven are you [ __ ] kidding me
how am I gonna check tumblr god dammit
okay let's talk to this little guy I
excuse me sir would you happen to know
where we might have be able to find my
fine wifey
what are you talking man
never minding well what happens if we
pull this lever this looks like a model
of a rocket well I could stick it up
your eyes what do we got here
oh it's a Yoshi tire do you know where
we find Wi-Fi Wi-Fi bad damn man familiy
I think the cafe has it you keep heading
east
the super sure arigato young doggie I
owe you my life
good I love cookies okey [ __ ] you
oh jeez alright let's keep going I don't
know why I'm enjoying this game I feel
like I should not be like this as much
as I have all right I'll talk to you
what do you want do you know where we
can find y if I hadn't might know she's
upset cow dies puddle do you know where
to get the Wi-Fi what I can't hate do
you what how long is this come on come
on
where do you find Wi-Fi Wi-Fi yeah I
don't know she has now we heard that
that agree say save the chopper going
out and asking yourself I hate when
people yell thanks I guess now of course
we're still going up to talk to her
anyway
how do you talk with numbers anyway
well there's a giant bunny dog a [ __ ]
damnit I love but it's good but punch me
[ __ ] weirdest character ever
excuse me it's just a figure of speech
dependence Manson you're still wearing
that your color even up here in heaven
why wouldn't anybody it's like a badge
of honor they're really loyal Tiana what
a name is Amy goody-goody I watch I
don't [ __ ] know why am I playing this
I that oven looks like a smiling
I know ass it's a really pink oven and
this is head east sorry about that
I don't wanna explore everything alright
fine I'll talk to him whoa that dog is
fabulous
hmm safe what the rainforest then
manatees have been waiting for one of
these oh okay hi press I'm gonna have
Jenny's upset yeah this video is
probably gonna get a lot of [ __ ]
dislikes but hey yo love maybe like me
enjoyed watching or one more I don't
know where thank you but bucks worth it
is reloading attack the tail
they only know